[Music]
all his life rob hayes and trash shoes
the terrible corner three take it to me
on the outside
[Music]
yo
are those general releases
anthony leon tucker wears low tops and
so does robert hayes and no matter how
he tried
nothing ever changed
it's okay rob
hey did you know the human head weighs
eight pounds
until
one night
[Music]
inspired by the classic masterpiece like
mike
comes a film about what it's like to
walk a mile in the ultimate sneakerhead
shoes
yo rob what you doing in there man come
on we gonna be late for school
brah what are you doing in the bathtub
and pj tucker snicker collection i mean
this is amazing but my mom can't know i
got all these sneakers
this summer comes a story about what
happens when a sneaker closet
becomes a sneaker house
[Music]
one for every quarter of basketball
and how sometimes the only way to
survive high school is with a pair of
kobe six protrusions
are those grinches
you know it with of course fits to match
the kicks
[Music]
and if you're gonna be like the ultimate
sneaker head you're gonna have to play
like the ultimate sneaker hat son we're
moving you to center center but i'm
built like a small forward
[Music]
it's crazy i keep making corner threes
like 40 of them too
people keep taking pictures of me on the
way to the gym
that is sick man
but with great power
comes great responsibility
what come on rob you're hanging out with
joe lapuma instead of me a br cakes
movie event where rob and jamelle find
their soul
and it's crazy that them joins fell
apart in walmart man i'm sorry let me
tell you something
the shoes have been inside you this
whole time bruh
and become
like pj
uh
i think i'm gonna like being pj tucker